>>Student: Oh, see numbers as a spiral.
>>Blair: So what do we have
to do to solve our problem?
>>Students: Prepare.
>>Blair: Prepare.
>>Teacher: Because of the use of
the problem solving procedure,
students are becoming more and more
confident in understanding the problem.
They find a strategy that's
going to work best for them.
It gives them that sense
of independence.
>>Alexa: At Concourse Village Elementary
School, we want children to analyze,
contribute and communicate.
We consistently ask children
to make their thinking visible,
so that their ideas are clearly
communicated with the world.
>>Blair: Good morning, good morning.
>>Alexa: So for example, in math,
you will see children use the
problem solving procedure.
It's a five step process. The
children are able to take us
through their thinking of how to
unpack their math word problem.
>>Rachel: First you read the problem to
understand it, then you think about it.
Then you solve the problem, then
you describe how you solve it,
and last is your connections.
We use the procedure so it's
easier to understand the problem,
and when you're looking at
it, you know what to do.
>>Blair: High five, love
what you're doing.
>>It helps them to become more
organized with their thoughts.
It becomes almost like
a checklist for them.
It's also important because
their reading skills are going
to improve also throughout
the whole entire time.
They're really honing
in on specific words,
so it's going to help them get the gist
and really understand the
content of what they're reading.
>>Rachel: The math problem
was about JC and Emma.
They were playing this game on
their computer and they were trying
to see who got the most points.
>>Blair: So who made the
most points I each round?
>>In the first step, we're asking
scholars to understand what they read.
We want them to annotate those important
words, to circle their questions,
and we create a "what I know" chart.
>>Student: The third
round, Emma has 62,984.
>>Blair: We also want them to
write their "I have to" statement.
What do they have to do in
order to solve this problem?
It solidifies in their
head what the intention
and what the goal is of their problem.
>>Student: I think it means how
they compare their information.
>>Ariel: After you understand,
you think. You've got to think
about your strategy and
then you'll do an "I will".
>>Blair: I will use a table, I will
multiply, I will add, I will divide.
In the third set, they're solving.
>>Rachel: I compare who got
the most points in each round,
and who got the most points altogether.
I mostly work by myself, and some
of the help is from my friends.
>>Student: Look, Rachel,
it's 7,000 plus 4,000.
He got 52,000 plus 200.
>>Blair: In the fourth step,
they are communicating.
Their communication involves
labelling and making sure
that their answers are clearly
written and they're explained.
>>Rachel: Because when
someone looks at your problem,
and it's not just you looking at it,
they have to understand
what you're writing.
You're trying to show how
you're solving the problem.
>>Blair: They're going to then create
connections regarding any other math
that they've done previously.
So they're going to look at the
numbers, identify if they're even
or odd, greater than, less than.
Then they have to provide
a sentence for that
and explain their thinking even further.
>>That's good recognition.
>>Student: That's right.
>>Alexa: So through the
problem solving procedure,
we would see their entire
thinking process of how
to unpack this word problem.
It has to be very clear and
visible so that anyone that picks it
up is able to make meaning.
Then we know their strengths
as a mathematician,
versus just getting the right answers.